the Joe Rogan experience but there's
also something to just the spectacle of
Tony Ferguson and just engage he just
going at it I mean like wild five round
slugfest with no audience do you think
that fight would have been different if
a crowd was there no no no I don't think
so maybe but I don't think so it's
possible I think Justin had a game plan
and he executed it brilliantly and I
think Ferguson mean he's always gonna be
Tony Ferguson he's one of the toughest
men that's ever walked the face of the
earth but I think he was preparing for a
grappler you know he's preparing for
khabib nurmagomedov and that fight
didn't take place it was supposed to
take place in April so he'd been
training for khabib by the way this is a
fifth time that fight was canceled the
fifth time the fight with Tony could be
was cancelled so Tony's been training
for khabib for [ __ ] years right so
he's ready for this elite grapple or
takes everybody down smashes him he's
trying to he's sitting at cutting him
from the bottom he's thinking of
submitting him and scrambling and
getting leg locks and all these
different things that he's thinking of
and then he's fighting an all-american
wrestler who does not want to go to the
ground he was nasty striking so it's a
totally different game plan and he has
to make an adjustment over a period of
just a few weeks and so Justin's fight
is I mean Justin always fights the same
way so Justin's adjustments warrant is
nearly as big Tony's Tony how to make
some some big adjustments but Justin
just fought a masterpiece the way he
fought was just magnificent and he
listened to his coaches so well there's
a point during the fight where trevor
Wittman is telling him you're hitting
him too hard you're swinging for the
bleachers he just just take about ten
percent off your punches he hit him with
good clean shots and he immediately made
that adjustment and then his cardio
leveled out because he was getting tired
towards the end of the second and
because he was just throwing just bombs
and we every shot he trying to take Tony
Ferguson's head off but you can't knock
Tony out with one shot he's in humanly
tough in humanly tough
so Justin backs it off a little bit and
just is thrown clean shots and then
winds up just dominating them and then
then they stop it in the fifth round
what's the one thing you learned like
like was there something you took away
from this experience that you liked you
didn't take away from any other it was
interesting
it was interested I felt very very
fortunate to be there oh my god all the
people that could be here to watch one
of the greatest fights of all time I
felt super fortunate that I was one of
those people that got to be there
I felt like real fortunate for that like
everything about it was like I was like
take it in the moment and just like
really cherishing it and like wow this
is amazing like not a lot of people get
to do this not a lot of people get to
experience this not a lot of people get
to do commentary for the UFC period but
to do commentary for championship fights
in this arena where there's no one there
so we're gonna 15 thousand seat arena
and there's maybe ten people in the
audience so why didn't need arena that
bit we were talking about that we could
have done this in the hotel yeah I'm
gonna get a conference room why they did
that but is it a spectacle of having a
big arena just to say you did it I think
there's something to that to letting
everybody know hey these these are
strange strange times you know we're in
the middle of this health crisis and so
this is the response to this health
crisis we're gonna do this [ __ ] in this
arena
[Applause]